they've been pouring through the world
non-stop Demaryius joy the East German
tribe and students coughing and
spluttering in the strangers traffic
jams West Berlin has ever seen there
were other strange happenings too
spontaneous acts of high-spirited
foolishness the flood was too much for
the hapless East German border guards at
checkpoint charlie
they were swamped they simply gave up
open the gates and allowed thousands
through the one crossing point that had
remained firmly closed elsewhere they
were swarming over the wall hacking at
it with hammers picks and chisels
clawing at it with bare hands most East
Germans had come for the sheer devilment
of it tens of thousands of them
pocketing the $100 mark they're entitled
to from West Germany's federal coffers
and roaming the streets in a mixture of
utter disbelief and glee West Berliners
greeted their brothers and sisters from
the east with jubilation having
themselves been surrounded by the
world's most heavily guarded border for
three decades Chancellor Helmut Kohl
couldn't resist coming to West Berlin to
join it he was accompanied by his
foreign minister Hanna Dietrich densha
and former Chancellor Billy Brandt who
as mayor of West Berlin witnessed the
wall going up it was an emotional visit
made even more poignant by the fact that
they chose to address the crowds on the
very spot where back in 1963 American
President John F Kennedy proclaimed it's
been an Berliner it was here that mr.
Kenter announced that East Germany had
started tearing down the wall creating
new and permanent border crossings in
order that as East Germany's leader Egon
Krenz put it East Germans could enjoy
their newfound freedom and enjoying it
they are the bottom line is that on this
side of the Berlin wall here Christmas
government is lurching from crisis to
crisis on this side here coal is facing
massive problems - the irony is that
they each going to have to rely on the
other's help just sort it out this is
Scott Chisholm on the Berlin Wall for
Sky News